hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute starten wir mal mit einer neuen
Kategorie Sallys 5 Minuten und zwar ist
es ein Kartoffel Omelett ich mache das
ganze aber mit Lachs später oben drauf
kommen jetzt riskiers halt oder no risk
no fun
[Musik]
dafür
das heißt es sind wirklich Zutaten die
sind ganz ganz einfach und ich zeige
euch mal eben ich verwende dafür etwas
Olivenöl eine rote Zwiebel Kartoffeln
fünf Eier Salz und Pfeffer das war's
schon jetzt schäle ich die Zwiebel und
die Kartoffeln
[Musik]
dann gebe ich jetzt hier schon mal etwas
Olivenöl in die Farben Pfanne am besten
nehmen wir jetzt eine beschichtete
Pfanne
und ich habe hier die Kartoffeln
normalerweise bei den Kindern wirklich
sie auch ganz gerne aber ich mache das
jetzt ein bisschen im Rösti Stil und
nehme jetzt hier einfach so eine Hobel
da habe ich diesen Julian Aufsatz mit
dabei aber ihr könnt wie gesagt auch
Würfel schneiden jetzt direkt in die
Pfanne
[Musik]
so sehen jetzt die Kartoffeln aus
richtig schön fein und die kommen jetzt
direkt hier auf den Herd und werden
angebraten bis sie gar sind
und dann können wir in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Zwiebel schneiden in Ringe
und die Eier mit Salz und Pfeffer
verrühren mit ordentlich Salz und
Pfeffer
soll ich zeigen wie man die Zwiebel
schält und schneidet
der elektrisch ich weiß wie man das
macht
und jetzt einfach die Eiermischung
drübergießen und fest werden lassen erst
von der einen Seite braten und dann
umdrehen und die andere Seite braten
das nicht ganz fest aber ich denke mir
so kommen
hier ist unser Omelett
und wir lieben Omelette ich serviere das
jetzt hier mit etwas sauren Sahne
bisschen Salz und Pfeffer und etwas
räucherlages
[Musik]
fertig ist wie heißt denn das
ja und fertig ist meine Rösti Omelette
mit Lachs
[Musik]
Omelett
ja
im Sommer erstmal auch total gerne
einfach einen frischen Salat dazu zu aus
dem Garten bisschen Tomaten und Gurken
perfekt ein perfektes Mittagessen oder
Abendessen das Rezept dazu gibt es in
meiner App auf sallys-blog.de schaut
euch gerne an probiert gerne aus und
wenn ihr weitere 5 Minuten Rezepte wollt
dann schreibt mir gerne in die
Kommentare bis dann tschüss
[Musik]